- where I am Patrick Todd I am she does
global color artist I'm here with your
very own Lottie winter I'm gonna show
you guys how to look that I created on
Adriana Lima in can it was a bold like a
bright pink lip with just minor matters
yeah Matt I'm gonna use some new
products that I'm super excited to share
with you guys today let's go right to it
I'm gonna start off by applying some
blush I'm gonna put this right onto the
apples of your cheeks I love that it's
super natural and it's super like
effortless I mean I personally think I
personally think so just cuz I love
blush i dip ties everything together but
a lot of it kind of like that so the
next product is highlighter and I think
magic that I did making a ted-like
sparkles it's literally diamonds a face
so what's really great about this
highlighter is that it has a 12 hour
aware it's subtle when you want it to be
an it's like impactful when what ya hero
la máscara ink whenever I'm looking for
a massacre I want a mascara that is
really gonna amplify my lashes will
still make them look natural and like
twinkly but this one is a 12 are aware
but if you ever make mistakes and get
like a little bit of mascara on your
skin the trick is to let it dry and then
it just it just picks off so for the
most exciting part of it make it look so
I'm gonna choose a lipstick now these
are brand new
you're the first to use them just a
moment look at the tail on that all
night it's super creamy it's super
hydrating they're gonna run around doing
my class okay pretend I get blowing a
kiss thank you
oh I think if you're ready for your
camera moment I don't think everything
is gonna but I put a little a little bit
of hair down
[Music]